in texas this week a civil forfeiture
hearing took a wrong turn
when the county attorney rod ponton
accidentally left a cat filter on his
zoom
so all of the parties privy to this
forfeiture hearing
uh zoomed into the call and you see a
judge and you see people wearing suits
and then there's this one county
attorney who would appear to be a
big fluffy cat and the
older gentlemen who were on this call
tried to figure out
how to proceed with the hearing despite
the presence of the
the giant cat i believe you have a
filter turned on in the video settings
you might want to uh
we're trying to can you hear me judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
i've got my assistant here she's trying
to but
oh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
i can i can see that i i believe you
uh mr attorney that you are not a cat uh
though that is
certainly the sort of thing a cat would
say if you were trying to crash a civil
forfeiture hearing
the thing about that legal hearing is
that it was still
much more serious and productive than
the fake impeachment trial that's going
on in washington dc right now
six republican senators
six republican senators voted with the
democrats
to continue this farce this fake
impeachment trial of the ex-president
in washington dc you had generally
speaking all the republicans were
against it because it's a sham and it's
unconstitutional
generally speaking you had all the
democrats for it because it's a sham and
it's unconstitutional which democrats
tend to enjoy
and then you had these six squish
useless republicans their names are
bill cassidy of louisiana susan collins
of maine
lisa murkowski of alaska mitt romney of
utah
ben sasse of nebraska and pat toomey of
pennsylvania
these people are
losers i don't i don't know how else to
put it you know i try not to use that
kind of blunt
language all the time i'm i don't
usually do my impression of don rickles
or donald trump for that matter
but there's no other way to put it these
guys are just losers
they may be illiterate i'm not sure i i
thought mitt romney was an intelligent
guy he founded bain capital that's
pretty impressive
ben sasse i think has a phd
but it would appear that they can't read
they certainly can't read the plain text
of the constitution
which makes it very clear even if you
had no other
historical or political sense
or or knowledge surely you could read
the constitution
which shows beyond a shadow of a doubt
that this proceeding
is preposterous let's get into the
constitution
we've alluded to it many times as we've
been talking about this sham
impeachment hearing but let's just get
to the plain text
where does impeachment come from kind of
impeachment we're talking of the
president of the united states
comes from two sections of the
constitution article two
section four reads the president
vice president and all civil officers
officers of the united states
shall be removed from office on
impeachment for
and conviction of treason bribery
or other high crimes and misdemeanors
donald trump is on trial right now sort
of in dc
donald trump is neither the president
nor the vice president nor any civil
officer
of the united states as such
he cannot be removed from office
notice i don't even need to get into how
preposterous it is
that they are what are they accusing him
of treason
how what what's the argument they don't
have any argument bribery no they sort
of tried that one that didn't quite work
high crimes and mr what's the crime
what's the i'm not even getting into
that i'm just saying as a purely
technical matter
the guy doesn't meet the criteria but
then it's even clearer when you get into
article one section three
which reads the senate shall have the
sole power
to try all impeachments okay we've that
that's working out right because the
senate is
holding whatever this trial is
goes on though when sitting for that
purpose
they the senate shall be on oath or
affirmation
when the president of the united states
is tried
the chief justice shall preside and nope
actually i want to pause right there
just to underscore the point
the president of the united states is
not being tried
so therefore this is not a
constitutional impeachment trial
furthermore the chief justice of the
supreme court is not presiding
some random democrat senator is
presiding
therefore this does not meet the
constitutional criteria of an
impeachment trial
the article goes on no person shall be
convicted
without the concurrence of two-thirds of
the members present judgment in cases of
impeachment
shall not extend further than to this is
very important
shall not extend further than to removal
from office
and disqualification to hold and enjoy
any office of honor trust or profit
under the united states
goes on so
there can't be some additional
consequences but
but beyond that the only consequence
that you can have for this trial is
removal from office and not removal from
office or
removal from office and the prohibition
that you you can't run for office again
the one tangible thing that the
democrats think they can try to get here
is they can prevent trump from running
for president again
because they're so confident that he did
poorly in 2020 right that's why
that's why they're holding this
unprecedented sham impeachment trial
right it's because they're so confident
that they're so much more popular
joe biden most popular guy ever elected
right uh probably not their actions
would
would seem to undermine that contention
but furthermore
there cannot be that consequence here
because
the consequence of impeachment is
removal from office and
the prohibition from running again they
can't remove him from office
they can't remove him from office
because he's not in office
they can't do any of those things
because he's not the president
that's why they can't hold a legitimate
impeachment trial
and these people these six republican
losers
i've i've just had it with them i i
always try to say well you know susan
collins she's in a tight spot
i'm requesting yeah romney did this one
like sort of semi-okay thing maybe once
i don't know
he's a good family man that's what you
always say about politicians that you
can't say anything nice about you say
he's a good family man ben sass i said i
guess he's sort of
says conservative things sometimes but
then he doesn't act in a conservative
manner
but i'm at my wit's end if these guys
can't read the text of the constitution
stand up for something that actually
matters then then what's
what's the point of them
they i guess i guess the point of them
is
this category that we've been talking
about on the show a lot which is they
are
court jester conservatives they exist
to do a little soft shoe do a little
dance kind of pretend to say some
conservative things and then
ultimately to legitimize the liberal
regime their job is
ultimately to lose i was thinking you
know
forget these guys can't read the
constitution
even if they could read the constitution
they clearly don't understand politics
democrats would never do this sort of
thing because it's politically
masochistic
it's not based on any principle it's
just it's just
so so wrong so i thought maybe these
guys just don't understand the politics
but then i thought you know maybe they
do understand the politics
maybe they do understand the politics
and they're just not
on our side that's even worse isn't it
either way this this really should be
the end of their political careers
i guess it probably won't be but it
certainly should be
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you